while the tournament was fast and it was
definitely an exciting event to watch a
big congratulations to our tournament
Victor Fabiano Karana who takes home the
first place prize and the Beautiful
singfield Cup trophy Bobby
congratulations this I thought it was
the full thing and there is our winner
kind of expecting a speech not just not
just not just a pretty picture but
I was thinking the whole thing was about
to be picked up and handed over that's
still a really lovely Trophy and really
I expected him to say thank you to the
commentators for the wonderful job that
they did the fans watching for the fans
and there he is 13 GCT points in his
pocket that's really he is looking gold
for uh the grand chest but I'm at 33
total gcd points $40,000 a lot of
earning there adding it to his purse of
his grandchester still winnings and for
me yes so impressive the way he made his
comeback from the
rapid really two points down coming in
today he overcame that and uh it it
actually required for for mvl to have a
nightmare we thought mediocre day for
mvl might be enough if somebody has a
fantastic day but if my mental math
which is never particularly good at this
time of day is correct Fabby only in
this field nothing is only but he only
scored six out of nine he didn't have
like an an outstanding day with like a
near near 100% score had five out of n
yesterday six out of nine yeah he scored
six out of nine and that was enough to
overturn a two-point def deficit so mvl
scored three and a half out of nine yeah
SE